des missions en série vague de rupture
conventionnelle depuis plus d'un an le
malaise et palpable sur le marché du
travail en France mais qui sont ces
salariés qui ont décidé de tout plaquer
de démissionner et même de se
reconvertir quels sont leurs motivations
parviennent-ils réellement à changer de
vie professionnelle
dans le 12e arrondissement de Paris nous
faisons la connaissance de Monty 38 ans
au fil des années la jeune femme gravit
les échelons au sein de grandes
compagnies d'assurance elle réalise un
parcours sans faute jusqu'au jour où
elle se questionne sur son travail sur
son utilité
des réunions qui sont pas très utiles
des présentations
urgentes mais que finalement personne ne
lit et au fil des années après
l'enthousiasme du début c'est vraiment
une perte de sens de ce que je faisais
et le sentiment que ça que ça servait à
rien
[Musique]
mon type se rend au travail la boule au
ventre et pense alors à quitter son
emploi mais l'angoisse de ne pas
retrouver un salaire équivalent la peur
du vide et même l'entourage rendent la
démarche difficile
je me disais mais mes parents ont
beaucoup travaillé
ce sont beaucoup sacrifiés pour que je
puisse suivre les études que j'ai
suivies est-ce que c'est pas égoïste
d'aller vers le choix
du cœur de suivre une passion est-ce que
c'est pas
est-ce que c'est pas des raisonnable
et puis finalement et finalement
j'ai écouté mon cœur
après une bonne dose de courage mon tir
retrouve les bancs de l’école de la
Chambre Syndicale de la Couture
Parisienne la jeune femme se met à créer
de ses propres mains alors qu'avant
c'était plutôt l'inverse
[Musique]
quand j'étais en cabinet de conseil en
disait que j'avais une bonne exécutante
et je trouve ça horrible
parce que ça veut dire que tu exécutes
des tâches et que tu sais pas ce que tu
fais
2 ans plus tard et un diplôme en poche
Monty monte son entreprise de patron de
couture elle réalise des schémas pour
que quiconque puisse fabriquer de chez
soi ses propres vêtements ça c'est le
patron de la robe que je porte
terminez les open space et des salles de
réunion mon titre travaille depuis son
petit appartement parisien ce qu'elle
aime c'est le côté artistique de son
nouveau métier mais elle doit également
se faire à son statut de chef
d'entreprise et à l'aspect reconversion
créée avec ses mains etc mais il y a le
côté je vends aussi des produits je il y
a une entreprise à faire tourner il y a
voilà pour que ce soit pour que ce soit
pérenne
cherchez sans cesse de nouveaux clients
rentabiliser son entreprise et se
plonger dans la comptabilité la jeune
femme cumule les contraintes et un
salaire plus faible mais peu importe
elle a trouvé un métier qui lui
ressemble et qui a du sens à ses yeux
mais au fait qu'est-ce qu'un travail qui
a du sens
le sens du travail c'est un travail qui
donne aux salariés le sentiment d'être
utile socialement de pouvoir travailler
sans contrevenir à ses valeurs morales
et professionnelles c'est-à-dire avoir
le sentiment de pouvoir faire un bon
travail de faire un travail de qualité
et la troisième dimension c'est un
travail qui permette à la personne de se
développer professionnellement de mettre
en oeuvre ses habiletés de pouvoir
apprendre de son travail la crise du
covid a sans doute servi de catalyseur à
grand nombre de salariés qui le temps du
confinement ont interrompu le fil de
leur existence pour se poser des
questions sur leur choix de carrière et
de vie une démarche qui touche toutes
les catégories socio-professionnelles
contrairement à une idée reçue vouloir
trouver du sens à son travail ça n'est
pas seulement la panache des cadres ou
des professions les plus qualifiées et
d'ailleurs on montre que
trouver très peu de sens à son travail
rend malade autant les ouvriers que les
cadres c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont une
probabilité équivalente de déclencher un
épisode dépressif c'est salarié en quête
de sens sont nombreux mais tous ne
parviennent pas forcément à mener à bien
leur reconversion l'idée c'est de
mélanger plus de de plantes un peu
unique
Gaëlle a passé 8 ans dans une entreprise
de conseils elle avait pour mission
d'aider les entreprises à réduire leur
empreinte carbone
alors j'ai adoré mon métier et puis en
faisant un stage dans une ferme
pédagogique j'ai eu l'occasion de mettre
les mains dans la terre et d'être dehors
et de passer beaucoup moins de temps
derrière l'ordinateur et donc c'est là
que j'ai compris qu'en fait j'avais
besoin d'explorer d'autres choses et de
démarrer ce projet de reconversion
Gaëlle quitte son cabinet de conseils et
rond son CDI à 33 ans la jeune femme se
lance dans la culture de plantes
médicinales deux ans de formation
proches de la nature et le sentiment
d'être utile
la santé naturelle et puis le contact
avec les clients c'est agréable quand
ils reviennent et qui sont contents
qu'on ait pu les aider sur des problèmes
des des petits problèmes quotidiens
aujourd'hui la jeune femme a des doutes
elle n'est plus si sûr de son choix elle
semble même regretter son ancien métier
bien plus confortable niveau salaire
c'est salarié en quête de sens sont de
plus en plus nombreux selon un sondage
récent un Français sur 4 souhaiterait
démissionner dans les prochains mois
[Musique]